well not always aftershocks immediately
after campaigns the first one of the
2018 midterms arrived pretty quickly
this afternoon the president fired his
attorney general Jeff Sessions for more
than a year the president has publicly
criticized and ridiculed sessions so it
was not very surprising now the
president has assured the ability of
replacing sessions with a new
appointment since Republicans held the
Senate clearly he saw no reason to keep
him around now in theory going forward
jeff sessions could challenge doug jones
in 2020 to reclaim the Alabama Senate
seat that he gave up to serve the
President as AG if he did that he'd
almost certainly win he's one of the
most popular people in the state we
asked source close to sessions and he
said that's probably not gonna happen in
sessions we'll probably just retire into
private life and if he does that of
course we will wish him the best but it
will be and we should say this a loss
for the country Donald Trump's longshot
presidential campaign succeeded because
he promised what so many voters wanted
and yet what so few politicians were
willing to campaign on because they are
cowards
among his many promises the most
important was his pledge to reverse
decades of deliberate neglect and treat
our national borders like they're real
like our country matters nobody
understood that message better than Jeff
Sessions he understood it immediately he
was one of the president's first and
most unwavering supporters I think the
first in the Senate and it was because
of immigration when the president took
office he gave up an essentially
lifetime post representing Alabama to
help fulfill Trump's mission
sadly the country was going another way
within about five minutes of the 2016
election Democrats decided their defeat
was not about immigration or an
abandoned middle class it was instead
you'll remember about Russia and the
conspiracy between Vladimir Putin and
Trump now Republicans said they didn't
believe that story and yet for some
reason many of them allowed Democrats to
reframe the entire political debate in
the country and make Russia the single
biggest issue in American politics but
Jeff sessions did not fall for that he
never let himself get distracted from
the mission at hand
well everyone else obsessed over
dossiers and FISA warrants
fashions worried about the mission he
was hired to do he introduced a zero
tolerance approach to immigration
prosecution he treated the illegal entry
into the United States as a crime
because it is a crime
his DOJ issued new opinions to restrict
the exploitation of asylum laws in this
country he fought to strip federal
funding of sanctuary cities courts ruled
against him but he did everything he
could to get those things done
his apartment accelerated the hiring of
immigration judges didn't get a lot of
attention but it's a big deal more cases
can be heard in deportations can take
place more quickly that's a service to
America and also by the way to the
people being held on daca sessions is
refusal to defend that program which is
unconstitutional really induced the
president to end the program sessions
wasn't just effective an immigration
though he rolled back the Obama
administration's soft on crime policies
across the board he pursued tougher
penalties for drug dealers that earned
the condemnation not just of liberals
but of wealthy libertarians who decided
the war on drugs was a total disaster
this at a time when more people were
dying every year of drug Odie's than
died during all vietnam but the decadent
decided oh it's immoral to prosecute
drug dealing okay
the population knew differently because
their relatives were dying of course
sessions also ended the Obama
administration's harassment of local law
enforcement that helped drive a surge in
violent crime in major cities if you
live in one you know we're talking about
sessions did all of this even as the
president who appointed him attacked him
in public those attacks started more
than a year ago after one of the
president's public rebukes we traveled
with sessions just by chance to El
Salvador where he was pushing a fight
against ms-13 sessions made it clear he
was in the cabinet to get results and
would serve as long as the president
would have him he has said again and
again in many different forms like this
barrage that we should have acted
differently we should have not accused
herself from oversight of the Russian
investigation do you agree with that
well you know I understand his feelings
about it because this has been a big
distraction for him but Tucker
I talked to experts and Department of
Justice people who are trained in that
I'm confident I made the right decision
you said the criticism was hurtful and
the president has made it really clear
that he doesn't seem to want you to run
Department of Justice will you continue
well he can make that clear at any time
I serve at the pleasure of the president
if he wants to make a change he can
certainly do so and I would be glad to
yield in that circumstance no doubt
about it
sessions wasn't perfect obviously you
never seen like an especially good
administrator of a large agency he
sometimes got rolled by his staff the
Russian investigations have shown that
FBI and DOJ are deeply politicized in
sessions never seem to fully get a
handle on the permanent bureaucracy
beneath them but if you take three steps
back here's what you see in an
administration but set with constant
leaks and infighting and people looking
out for themselves and only themselves
sessions was maybe one of the very few
people who never forgot why he was there
to make America a better country we can
only hope that his replacement will do
the same